how much fun as I just have a sister's
night out we did the men are I mean fine
this is our first red carpet together in
two years two years because she was
pregnant forever away and tell us where
are we at with wedding planning so I'm
kind of bad but I have a date and I
found the dress and everything between I
don't have but I'm working on the save
the dates right now so you found the
dress that's alma mater I know I mean
you go to the fashion shows and then I
see Marchesa I cut end they give me
Pierre's away when I walk in a macaron
and then have this amazing collection
and I'm sold all right give us a vibe of
the wedding in one word black-tie
classic well that's not really one word
a classic classic you've had the baby
but you look amazing what were your
secret you well you know what it is is
no one told you how hard it'd be to put
a stroller in and out of like a car like
so many times a day carry your pump bag
carrying your babies how much I never
knew I could love something so much and
I just adore her like she's my own so
she and I have this bond that's just
amazing did that will deliver experience
make you want to do it again I know
right no it makes me scared to death but
I definitely next fall where you start
trying again cuz birdie does need a
sibling getting baby zebra elopement
yeah you know you would think but being
around this one a lot I'm actually like
hey John I'm with you no kids a lot of
people don't tell you like what it's a
full-time job and you for women you
sacrifice not only your body but your
life like I'm so career driven that I
couldn't do what she does right now I
here it's me moms are amazing we are
you